you know for 50 years
to be sound old but in my head I think
I'm 20. so as long as you keep that in
mind you never you never get on
I kiddo you know you can listen but I
talk to the new people Aikido either you
get it or you don't that's the way I see
it I've done Tai Chi yoga meditation I
do healing work I do all sorts of things
but somehow I kiddo I can't quite get it
so I keep going
and and my training really nowadays is
teaching
because I'm working more on the subtle
things and at my level just a few
centimeters you know a few centimeters
out and make the whole difference of
whether it will work or not work
at the different stages from beginner
all the way through the black lights
they can make lots of errors but still
think they're making it work
and the person falls down and you say no
I must have got it I like that technique
so I must have got it where really the
higher you get the more you realize that
in the end if you can take a piece of
tracing paper and pull it through the
gap
that's about as close as you need to
really get it so it's very it's a it's a
martial art that is for I think for
perfectionists and with a perfectionist
you'll never perfect it so that means
you can keep doing it till you die oh
Okay so
we go
so
we always start with um
four movement of coupling with your
partner
and for many years you'll do it and
not really get much out of it you do it
because the teacher shows you to get
out so you just keep doing it
but in the end you realize that this is
like the letter A the alphabet it's it's
actually the most important part of
like uh is the man now
why is that
I'm already connected with him you know
if we could see auras and energies just
by putting my hand out there I'll
automatically connect with him well
before he gets to me I smell stimulate
the from the toe to the hands
by then my hands are going in his
Direction but he's coming this direction
so I have to couple up and make this
shape so now my fingers are going in his
Direction
that's the direction of his energy
so at my level that's what I'm thinking
about I'm thinking more about the the
flow
of movement than I am
gonna have to move him you know if I
hold you
and give him a hundred percent in the
grip
he's got to overcome that somehow one
day he's got to overcome it okay